comment faire que les humains dans très
longtemps comprennent que la à cet endroit
précisément il ya un danger depuis l'egypte
antique les chats sont toujours associés aux
humains les humains qui fléchit et donc ils
ont fait un chat qui lorsqu'ils s'approchent
d'un déchet radioactif devient violet et sont dit
si les humains dans 500 ans on voit ça ils vont
se dire il ya un truc dès que le chat va dans
cette forêt il y a quelque chose qui se passe
donc là on veut juste pas abîmer les
capteurs qui sont à l'entrée de cette
première galerie c'est pour ça
qu'on ralenti tout simplement
bonjour à tous bienvenue que vous avez pu le voir
dans les images juste avant je me suis retrouvée
il y a quelques temps à 500 mètres sous terre
alors j'ai eu la chance de visiter cigéo c'est
le centre industriel de stockage géologique et
donc cette vidéo est réalisée en partenariat
avec l’ANDRA, l’Agence Nationale pour la Gestion
des Déchets Radioactifs. Alors on se calme, ce
n’est pas une vidéo publicitaire, je ne vais pas
essayer de vous vendre la technologie nucléaire
et vous affirmer que c’est la solution à tous nos
problèmes, mais je vais essayer de vous expliquer
pourquoi, quand on est archéologue, la question
des déchets nucléaires peut être passionnante.
Pourquoi une émission sur une chaîne d’archéologie
parlerait de déchets nucléaires ? Que viennent
faire des sciences humaines et sociales dans
un domaine habituellement chasse gardée des
physiciens ? La réponse ne m’a pas parue évidente
au départ, et j’avoue que mes connaissances sur le
sujet étaient plus qu’approximatives. On connaît
un peu en archéologie la radioactivité, puisque
le carbone radioactif, le carbone 14 nous permet
de faire des datations, on connaît surtout très
bien les déchets, éclats de silex, pots cassés et
autres poubelles antiques, mais l’association des
deux était quelque chose pour moi d’assez nouveau.
Les déchets radioactifs sont de plusieurs natures.
Ce peuvent être des déchets issus de la médecine,
de la recherche, de la défense ou de l’industrie
non électronucléaire, mais ceux qui font le
plus parler d’eux sont bien sûr les résidus
des combustibles des centrales nucléaires. Ces
déchets-là peuvent être hautement radioactifs,
c’est-à-dire que le rayonnement qu’ils produisent
peut être très dangereux pour les organismes
vivants. Je vous renvoie vers une vidéo de
l’ANDRA qui explique ça très clairement puisque
ce n’est pas le sujet dont je vais parler ici.
L’ANDRA est donc l’organisme public en France
qui gère ces déchets depuis 1979. Elle les stocke
dans des centres le temps que leur radioactivité
diminue et cherche des solutions pour que leur
impact soit le plus minime possible sur nous
et les générations futures. Car le fond du
problème est là, les déchets nucléaires ont
une durée de vie gigantesque. Certains resteront
nocifs plusieurs centaines de milliers d’années.
La question qui se pose à l’ANDRA et à
tous ceux qui réfléchissent à la gestion
des déchets nucléaires n’est pas qu’une question
technologique. Même si cela demande des années
d’études de terrain comme avec Cigeo, sceller
une caisse de béton ou un cylindre d’acier à 500
mètres de profondeur n’a rien de scientifiquement
impossible. Mais comme ce n’est pas mon domaine
de spécialité, je vais laisser ces considérations
techniques à d’autres. L’autre mission de l’ANDRA,
celle qui nous intéresse, est aussi de faire
comprendre aux citoyens la nécessité de ce
travail de gestion, et de faire en sorte que l’on
garde la mémoire de ces sites de stockage pendant
au moins cinq siècles. Durée pendant laquelle
il faut absolument éviter toute intrusion
qui exposerait dangereusement les personnes.
Deux scénarios sont possibles : 1, la mémoire du
site se conserve bien ; 2, la mémoire du site
se perd ou se dégrade. Dans le premier cas,
aucun problème, les déchets seront conservés
sous terre. Dans le deuxième cas, en revanche,
il existe un risque. Le site peut être oublié
pour toujours auquel cas, c’est tant mieux,
mais il peut aussi être redécouvert. Si c’est le
cas et que les découvreurs le fouillent sans que
sa dangerosité soit bien comprise, ils risquent
une exposition mortelle. Moralité, il n’y a que
le scénario 1 qui marche à tous les coups.
L’oubli, voilà l’enjeu qui nous intéresse.  Comment faire pour ne pas oublier ?
L’oubli touchetout et tout le monde, et il n’y a rien de plus imprévisible que la mémoire.
Ni l’un ni l’autrene peuvent se décréter. Pourquoi a-t-on retenu la date de la bataille de Marignan et pas cellede Pavie ?
Pourquoi apprend-on aujourd’hui que l’Empire romain s’est effondré en 476 alors quepersonne à l’époque n’y a fait attention ?
Ce sont  les chemins tortueux de la mémoire, et du sens que
nous donnons, aujourd’hui, à toutes ces choses.
La mémoire est donc un sujet d'histoire, qui nous
amène en toute logique à réexaminer le passé,
mais toujours en lien avec le présent. En
ce qui concerne les déchets nucléaires,
la mémoire ne résonne pas au passé mais au futur.
Comment évolueront nos sociétés dans les siècles
à venir ? Que penseront nos successeurs de
cette pratique de stockage ? Pour une fois,
c'est dans la projection que nous devons envisager
la mémoire, celle des générations futures.
Mais comment faire pour garder
la mémoire aussi longtemps ?
Nos anciens avaient trouvé une technique imparable
pour garder leurs données : graver dans le marbre.
Ainsi, des siècles et des siècles plus tard,
la Forma Urbis nous livre de façon fragmentaire
une carte antique de Rome. Si efficace et joli
soit-il, ce procédé n'est plus viable à l'heure
des Big Data (ou bien il faut sérieusement
repenser l'orientation professionnelle de nos
jeunes). Les « winners » en matière de sauvegarde
de données sont dernièrement des chercheurs
de Southampton ayant mis au point le procédé
sobrement intitulé « Superman memory crystal », un
disque de cristal capable de garder 13,8 milliards
d'années les chefs-d'œuvre de l'humanité. A
ce jour en ont bénéficié la Bible, le Traité
d'optique de Newton et la Déclaration Universelle
des Droits de l'Homme. Il faudra attendre un peu
avant de pouvoir sauvegarder nos selfies tous
pourris... Néanmoins, l'ANDRA a aussi recours
à la gravure sur disque de Saphir pour situer
l'emplacement des sites de stockage de déchets et
en détailler le contenu : à 25 000 € le support,
l'agence dispose de 3 disques dont la durée
de vie est tout de même d’un million d’années.
Une autre piste étudiée par l'ANDRA
est celle du son, langage universel,
laissant une forte empreinte sur la mémoire
de celui ou celle qui l'écoute et donc plus
à même de traverser les époques. Les sons
ont la particularité de véhiculer du sens,
des émotions et de se retenir facilement,
ne reste plus qu'à trouver un son capable de
transmettre la mise en garde à travers les âges.
L'ANDRA s'inspire aussi d'un principe plusieurs fois millénaire : pour ne pas oublieril faut des marqueurs dans le paysage.
Certains monuments ont réussi, eux, à ne jamais
être oubliés. Pensez aux pyramides de Gizeh,
des tas de pierres de 140 mètres de haut,
qui trônent depuis 5000 ans aux yeux de
tous. Le meilleur coup de com’ de l’histoire.
Mais quand on y pense, les pyramides sont presque
les seules constructions à avoir défié l’oubli.
Temples grandioses au Mexique, au Cambodge, en
Grèce ou en Italie, tant de constructions faites
pour durer toujours et qui ont sombré sous la
végétation ou les constructions postérieures. La
majorité des objets archéologiques sont oubliés,
enfouis, puis redécouverts. Justement ce
qu'on cherche à éviter dans notre cas.
Plutôt que d'ériger des pyramides
au-dessus des déchets nucléaires,
deux artistes (Stéphane Perraud et Aram
Kebabdjian) ont proposé à l'ANDRA en
2015 de matérialiser un site de stockage
par une forêt bleue. Cette Zone Bleue,
nom donné à l’œuvre, serait en réalité un site
touristique qui informerait les passants de la
dangerosité potentielle du lieu par sa couleur
originale. Le bleu, choisi en référence au « bleu
Tcherenkov », visible dans les réacteurs
nucléaires lors d'un phénomène de propagation
des ondes, traduit la nature des déchets dans
le sol. Pour faire mémoire, le choix est ici
celui de la vulgarisation, de l'exposition
au grand public et non de son camouflage.
Mais cela ne suffit pas, au-delà des
solutions matérielles, graver, sonner,
construire, il faut aussi investiguer le
processus mental et social de la mémoire.
Qu’est-ce qui fait qu’une société se souvient
ou non d’un lieu ou d’un événement ? Qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on décide de ne pas oublier ?
Pour imaginer cela dans le futur, on peut bien
sûr s’inspirer des exemples… du passé.
Les exemples du passé nous montrent qu’il est
extrêmement difficile de défier l’oubli. Prenons
le cas des épisodes de catastrophes naturelles,
qui causent des morts et des destructions.
Même des événements aussi marquants et
tragiques peuvent être aisément oubliés.
Au Japon jusqu’au début du XXe siècle, on
érigeait ainsi des bornes de pierre, placées dans
les champs à l’endroit où la vague d’un tsunami
s’était arrêtée, pour en garder la mémoire. Dessus
étaient gravées des indications, telles que la
date et un conseil adressé à ceux qui la liraient
: « ne construisez pas vos maisons en dessous de
cette limite ». Parfois respecté, souvent oublié,
ce conseil n’aura pas permis d’éviter les milliers
de victimes, lors de l’effroyable tsunami de 2011.
Autre exemple, les éruptions volcaniques.
En Italie, à proximité immédiate du Vésuve,
vivent encore des centaines de milliers de
personnes. Pourtant, personne n’ignore que le
volcan est actif, et qu’il a déjà rayé de la carte
des villes entières comme Pompéi et Herculanum.
Très bien décrite par les auteurs antiques, cette
éruption est toujours dans la mémoire collective
2000 ans plus tard. Si le volcan se réveillait,
il y aurait de très nombreuses victimes.
Dernier exemple, l’effondrement d’une montagne.
Dans le massif de la Chartreuse, en Savoie,
le mont Granier s’est en partie effondré
et a enseveli cinq villages en l’an 1248,
causant la mort de centaines de personnes.
La montagne présente toujours une falaise
instable et libère régulièrement des rochers qui
s’écrasent en contrebas. Cette zone reste toujours
inconstructible et interdite aux promeneurs. La
menace est évidente, imposante, comme le Vésuve,
mais cette fois-ci n’a pas été ignorée.
Si la mémoire du danger est plus ou moins
prise en compte dans ces trois exemples, c’est
qu’ils n’ont pas les mêmes contraintes sur les
sociétés. Il est en effet très facile de ne
plus construire sous le mont Granier en Savoie,
cela ne concerne que quelques hectares et
ne dérange pas grand monde. En revanche,
imaginer ne plus construire au bord de
la mer sur tout l’archipel du Japon,
ou évacuer définitivement toute la baie de
Naples est purement et simplement inimaginable.
Quand la contrainte est trop forte, quel que
soit le danger, l’avertissement risque bien
d’être sciemment oublié. On sait que le Vésuve
est dangereux mais il vaut mieux l’oublier,
se dire que ça n’arrivera pas ou qu’on aura
le temps de s’enfuir en cas d’éruption. Même
une mémoire bien entretenue ne garantit
pas que le problème sera pris en compte.
On l'a dit en début de vidéo, à première vue
l'association archéologie/nucléaire n'était
pas évidente. A présent, il apparaît clairement
que les considérations sociales et culturelles
occupent une large place dans le traitement
de nos déchets nucléaires. Le sujet de la
mémoire est un exemple parfait de ce que
peuvent apporter les sciences humaines et
sociales à des domaines techniques : il prouve
que le progrès technologique ne solutionne pas
tout. Les compétences techniques ne garantissent
pas leur réception par les sociétés. C'est pour
cette raison qu'au-delà d'une intelligence
technologique, des chercheurs s'emploient à
développer une intelligence sociale des
techniques.
La technique se heurte à la société et
inversement. Peu importe le risque et le
symbole mobilisé, si une société n'a pas
« envie » de gérer un problème, elle ne
le fera pas. L’ethnologie recense d'ailleurs
plusieurs cas de sociétés qui « bloquent » des
avancées technologiques pour être moins
contraintes socialement, en Amérique du Sud,
ou en Papouasie par exemple. Souvent ce rejet
est lié à une volonté de ne pas transformer le
rapport à la nature, du moins la représentation
que l'on s'en fait (cosmogonie, mythologie
et onirisme). Sahlins, Godelier, Descola dont
j'ai déjà présenté les travaux dans mes vidéos,
ont mis en évidence ces « systèmes de blocage » :
Les Papous en adoptant la hache métallique n'ont
pas pour autant intensifié leur productivité
agricole. Ce temps gagné par l'abandon des outils
de pierre, a été immédiatement utilisé pour faire
la guerre ou organiser des cérémonies rituelles,
pas pour cultiver plus. En Amérique du Sud
cette fois, plusieurs populations refusent
de domestiquer des espèces animales : c'est
le cas du pécari, petit cochon qui se prête
parfaitement à l'élevage. On connaît la technique,
on ne veut simplement pas l'appliquer. On n'a eu
par contre aucun mal à domestiquer il y
a 2000 ans le canard de Barbarie ou le
chien. Les choix faits par ces populations
sont d'ordre social, pas technologique.
Une technique qu'elle soit agricole, spatiale
ou nucléaire c'est en fait une relation entre
l'humain et l'outil : pour qu'elle soit retenue,
jamais oubliée, il faut que certaines conditions
sociales soient réunies. Cette idée estbien admise chez les archéologues et ethnologues
mais visiblement peu vulgarisée auprès du grand
public et des chercheurs des autres disciplines
scientifiques. Les techniques, paradoxalement,
ne sont pas des « choses » nous dit Descola,
mais plutôt des processus d'identification,
d'objectivation, qui permettent de mettre
un peu de soi à l'intérieur. Si l'objet est
impénétrable, non identifiable, ne renvoie à
rien de ce qu'un individu expérimente au cours de
sa vie, alors aucune attention n'y sera portée.
Il serait donc bien naïf de penser que la
menace représentée par les déchets nucléaires,
obligerait nos descendants à s'en préoccuper.
Car, qui nous dit que le nucléaire et ses
déchets ne seront pas tabous dans quelques siècles
? Qui nous dit que d'autres événements importants,
parfois tragiques, n'occuperont pas les
sociétés futures : guerres, épidémies,
révoltes et crise climatique occultant ces fameux
colis souterrains ? Impossible de le prévoir.
Peut-être qu'une mythologie du nucléaire
est à imaginer. Après tout, Achille,
Jésus et Bouddha font toujours parler
d'eux... Qu'elle soit orale ou écrite,
la transmission s'est faite. On pourrait
peut-être aussi supposer que pour qu'une
société s'occupe d'un problème, il faudrait que
les individus qui la composent vivent dans de
bonnes conditions. Si une large partie
de la population connaît la précarité,
des conditions climatiques de plus en plus
extrêmes et donc d'autres préoccupations, il
est peu probable qu'elle s'identifie au problème
de déchets invisibles légués par les ancêtres...
Alors que faire ?
Il faut, et c'est
ce que fait déjà l'ANDRA, associer les sciences
humaines et sociales à la réflexion. Tirer profit
des quantités d'exemples et de connaissances
accumulées par les anthropologues. Utiliser
pour une fois ces disciplines dont on nousrépète souvent qu'elles ne servent à rien,
sous prétexte qu'elles n'ont pas d'application
technique. Travail incertain et de longue haleine,
cette collaboration reste bien plus réaliste que
de miser sur un hypothétique oubli définitif.
Toutes les solutions imaginées jusqu'à présent
pour faire perdurer la mémoire se heurtent à
l'échelle du temps. On ne peut aujourd'hui
que concevoir des solutions assez durables
pour laisser le temps aux générations futures
de trouver leurs propres moyens de transmettre
la mémoire. Et surtout pour s'assurer
qu'elles n'oublient pas de le faire.
Moralité, partagez cette vidéo une fois par
mois à tout votre entourage et demandez à vos
enfants de faire pareil après votre mort, ça me
semble être la seule solution pour s’en souvenir.